we are told that a van drives around a
circular curve of radius R with linear
speed V on a second curve of the same
radius the van has linear speed
one-third V and you could view linear
speed as the magnitude of your linear
velocity how does the magnitude of the
Vans centripetal acceleration change
after the linear speed decreases so
pause this video and see if you can
figure it out on your own and I'll give
you a little bit of a hint we know that
the magnitude of centripetal
acceleration in general is equal to
linear speed squared divided by radius
the radius of the curve all right now
let's work through this together so
let's first think about the first curve
and so the first curve the magnitude of
our centripetal acceleration for curve
one I have another subscript one here
for us this is around the first curve
they tell us that our linear speed is V
so we're gonna have V squared over and
the radius of that curve is R so it's
just going to be straight up V squared
over R for that first curve the
magnitude of our centripetal
acceleration now what about the second
curve so the magnitude of our
centripetal acceleration around the
second curve that's what that two is is
going to be equal to they tell us we now
have a linear speed of one-third V so in
our numerator we're gonna square that
one-third V squared all of that over the
curve of the same radius so our radius
is still R and so let's just do a little
algebraic simplification one-third V
times one-third V is just going to be
1/9 V squared so it's going to be 1/9 V
squared over R all I did a square this
numerator here or I could write this as
1/9 times V squared over R and the
reason why I wrote this in green is
because this is the exact same thing as
this and so this is going to be equal to
this is equal to 1/9 times instead of
writing V squared over R I could say hey
that's our sin trip the magnitude of our
centripetal acceleration around the
first curve the magnitude of our
centripetal acceleration around the
first curve so how does the magnitude of
the van's a centripetal acceleration
change after the linear speed decreases
well around the second curve we have 1/9
the magnitude of centripetal
acceleration so we could say the
magnitude mag or I could just say well
they already asked us how does the
magnitude change
so we could say decreases decreases by a
factor factor of 9 and I wrote it in
this language you could say it got
multiplied by a factor of 1/9 or you
could say decreases by a factor of 9
because on the Khan Academy exercises to
deal with this they use language like
that let's do another example here we're
told a father spins his daughter in a
circle of radius R at angular speed
Omega
then the father extends his arms and
spins her in a circle of radius 2 R with
the same angular speed how does the
magnitude of the child's centripetal
acceleration change when the father
extends his arms once again pause this
video and see if you can figure it out
well the key realization here and we
derive we derived this in a previous
video is to realize that the magnitude
of centripetal acceleration is equal to
R times our angular speed squared and so
initially so the magnitude of our
centripetal acceleration initially I'll
do that with a sub I that is going to be
equal to well they're using the same
notation we have Omega as our angular
speed and our radius is R so it's just
going to be R Omega squared and then
when we think about the father he
extends his arms so then you have the
magnitude of your centripetal
acceleration I could say final or
extended I'll just say final sub F what
is that going to be equal to well now
though now our radius the circle the
radius of our circle is 2r so it's going
to be 2 R and they say the same angular
speed so our angular speed is still
Omega 2 R Omega squared well this part
right over here
our Omega squared that was just our the
magnitude of our initial centripetal
acceleration that was the magnitude of
our initial centripetal acceleration and
so you see that our said the magnitude
of our centripetal acceleration has
increased by a factor of two increased
increased by a factor of two and we're
done